so to start here I wanted to talk a
little bit about the directing
especially because you have a career
where you've worked with some of the
best of the best so I was wondering if
maybe one anyone gave you any advice
before jumping into this or maybe if you
were looking over someone's shoulder
while you were working on their film
yeah I mean every director I've worked
with in every movie I've watched and it
has influenced the way I directed and
including everybody I've ever spoken to
me you really do take your life
experience whenever you're creating any
art that's the only way that you that I
know how you could do it that said David
O'Russell is a huge part of giving me
the confidence to to direct a movie he
was so collaborative in the movies that
we did allowing me to really be a part
of it and the same way with Clint
Eastwood and Todd Phillips I've been
very lucky with I think I think maybe
they recognized that I wasn't looking at
it as an actor but looking at it as
someone to help them tell the story in
any way that they want me to be there
for and so I've been very very lucky I
could definitely tell I mean I can't say
enough about your performance - I'm a
huge American Horror Story fan and I'm
also familiar with your work with Robert
Rodriguez and then when you look at the
character here it is just so strikingly
different but I was wondering is there
anything about your experience working
on those two projects that you were able
to use here well you know I I had those
experiences so I had been on a set
before and I had worked you know
learning about cameras
you know where to stand and yeah you
know camera angles and things like that
but this was very different and I think
that every project is very different and
he's he's such a sensational director
you know like he would frame up the
shots with the ninja like precision and
then you know then let this explosion of
freedom happen on set and he he would
say you know you know all you got to do
is trust me he says it to Ali in the
movie he would say it to me on set and I
just felt like I could I could fly and
and and become somebody that's
completely not me I think one of my
biggest personal takeaways from the
movie is I walked out thinking about
overcoming self-doubt and also the
support system you have in your life and
how important it is to kind of sit down
and think about that list of names who
really made a difference so I was
wondering who are those people for you
and is there anyone out there that maybe
had the smallest influence and doesn't
know that you want to express that to oh
that's interesting
yeah I mean I think that that's the
beauty hopefully of you know a small
gesture can go such a long way you don't
even realize it that that's a hopefully
a lesson in humanity and just human
interaction how much I don't know I
think we all need each other in the most
essential way possible and that's sort
of one of the things that we were trying
to convey in this movie is what happens
with just two people believe in each
other but they're able to accomplish and
how hard life is at the same time that's
the dilemma absolutely one specific for
you for me it was my family always
encouraging me to be creative you know I
loved playing piano I loved writing
songs I loved acting and my parents
supported me in that and then my act
might
various acting teachers that I just you
know loved so much and I have to shout
out specifically down Lawrence my vocal
coach he believed in me so much heat
when I met him he was teaching like Mick
Jagger and we're working with Billy Joel
and he was working Christina Aguilera
all these a huge artists and I was just
this little girl and he said I have no
time for you and my schedule but I
believe in you so I'm going to make time
and I'm going to get a give it to you at
half the price so you know a hundred
people in the room you could have and
ninety and I don't believe in you and
just one does and it changes your whole
life and I feel the same way about
Bradley you know Bradley believed in me
and you know I really believed in him
and I still do all the time and I think
that shows itself in this film I think
you know if we didn't have that actual
connection and friendship you know
behind the scenes that it would be very
different but he captured the honesty of
our you know private friendship as well
as you know the the love story and the
trust that they have with each other and
how much they believe in each other and
how that makes their love soar